I told you I was getting serious and he
goes uh I think you probably pick up
listening to the show all right here's
the truth I feel like I have no idea
what my I feel like I have no idea and
maybe we've sort of talked about this
because I don't do stand-up yeah how I
don't ever get to the point no I feel
like I have no idea what the value is
out there for some of the dumb things
that I do because this guy was
definitely is definitely picking up on
the on the podcast that I'm very I'm
playing around but I'm definitely like a
[ __ ] you know whatever
here goes the podcast it's gone here's a
dumb wrestling joke and blah blah blah
and the diamond ting this and that we
want less listeners and all this [ __ ]
and those who are left you guys are our
diamonds you're the ones who get every
[ __ ] joke we value you more as you as
your you know compatriots fall off the
side this guy picked up on that and was
like hey you know this whatever the nice
things he said and he goes that's
something to be proud of will yeah I
don't think pride has any place in
comedy or entertainment I think it's a
thing it's a poison right yeah do you
think I you even saying it you've been
saying it you saying what you just said
you know struck a chord with me just now
yeah yeah I've never really thought of
it that way but you were correct pride
has no place in it don't pretend to cry
I'm not [ __ ] actually how you sound
when you yeah you've seen me cry you do
the broken voice like that yeah so I
grab feel like but don't touch me there
so I do feel the same thing yeah don't
was your Grandpa's name Bob no is that
why you're only Bob when you're serious
no I don't know his name so I kind of
feel like oh yeah I don't to take your
to take your audience to a new thing you
have to believe that there's an audience
that wants your will shut the [ __ ] up
I'm telling you right now all right all
right I'm not gonna you know just shut
the [ __ ] up for a second you guys you're
a guy who is a comedy
entity out there writer he was on a
sketch show for years
you were the star one of the stars of
MADtv during its prime yeah
all right I don't yet that was 35 years
ago yeah it doesn't [ __ ] matter it
wasn't right five years ago you dick
[ __ ] sorry go on your [ __ ] compliment
and you're playing [ __ ] right but
right now shirt since the show started
you make it any more naked you're making
me sad well just warm in here six people
is [ __ ] room all right blue eye all
right so we have one blue eye well I'm
just saying is you know I'm dumb no I'm
slept just listen to what I'm saying
I'm dumb I'm slapped I don't know
nothing right
nosotros paya to you and everyone you
know and the vibe is this is is that you
think that I think that people who
should listen to me I don't think so but
you know what I resonate with people
come here let me talk done it's a
[ __ ] miracle but I go up sorry why do
you do that I'm listening I'm just I
know but can I just say what I want to
say just say nice things about yourself
[Laughter]
all right let me let me everyone is very
respect and yeah you're very happy I am
I am NOT the most educated person but I
try and I'm not dumb I'm not [ __ ] by
my smart that better I'm not okay but I
go on the road I read emails I read a
little comments about myself I get the
artists like this artist I was just
noticing this art we just got this today
very look at an artist you know what's
his name
Alberto Reyes created these two yeah
right of me and kalila incredible and
you know he they write letter saying
that I help them and I'm motivating and
I'm uh and I don't know why so I just
keep doing it mm-hmm and I feel like
there is a reason why I should be doing
this podcast yes I don't
the endgame is I don't know what the end
result is gonna be that's not doing it
for money I'm doing it for just it you
know in many ways it reinvented myself
really how I think that you know if if
you were to read a book about Bobby Lee
you know there would be a chapter on
kalila the you know when I met kalila
yeah and what a big influence she is in
my life and this podcast has everything
to do with her but it also has
everything to do with the revival of my
career I wasn't working at all really
yeah until we started doing this and I
got a bunch of [ __ ] because of this and
I got because of this it doubled my road
audience okay it made me money yeah it
it did a lot of things and I'm not gonna
downplay my fans out there that listen
to Taco Bell a very they are my
foundation no stops papaya to you mm-hmm
and to your family and cons I have four
papayas no nosotros papaya means we are
no it doesn't it means we papaya we
papaya we provide yeah no we are I've
never been in a South Asian I've never
been to the Asia's it's not it's
Hispanic in origin well yeah but sorry
but like Filipino yeah we're Mexican
yeah you Mexican you're Mexican okay but
I think that by you doing a podcast is
important because there are people out
there that you might not necessarily
know right that relate to you I don't
know any of my audience will you meet
them ever oh yeah I meet them sometimes
years ago when we used to do live shows
yeah yeah yeah now they're on the
internet but what I do stand-up they
come to my show that's amazing thank you
well I don't do stand-up though
[Music]